another new chapter disney plus is the
mandalorian is here and once again
dinjarin aka mando played by pedro
pascal
and groku aka baby yoda find themselves
in quite the intergalactic pickle
chapter 14 is aptly subtitled the
tragedy as the episode ends with groku
and the clutches of the galactic
empire's maf gideon played by giancarlo
esposito further cementing himself as
one of the great go-to tv villain actors
not only does gideon recognize the power
that we little grogu possesses but he
also appears to have a sinister plan for
it
of course works of great evil are rarely
accomplished alone
gideon has an impressive team of baddies
working with him to make things hard and
poor din
one of those hench people is his comms
officer a small role but one that has
appeared during several crucial moments
of the series
the character is played by actress and
martial artist katie o'brien
if seeing her in chapter 14 of the
mandalorian gave you flashes of deja vu
you're not just being tricked by those
cumbersome hats the empire makes its
officers wear
before she joined up with mock gideon
o'brien already had an impressive resume
of roles in a variety of genre tv
projects
including a few other henchwomen parts
you may recognize her from
after a string of small roles on shows
like the walking dead and how to get
away with murder o'brien landed her
first significant part through z nation
sci-fi's take on the zombie apocalypse
genre she joined the cast in the fifth
and final season playing georgia george
sinclair
george is a capable leader of a group of
survivors trying to start a new and more
fair society
but as many visionaries in the
apocalypse learn even things like safety
and not dying or hard sells on a
citizenry shell shocked by disaster for
brian the role was a natural fit
during an interview with ochi magazine
she explained i felt very connected to
george as a character so it was easy to
pull from my past and what i see in the
world today to help me relate to her i
was very much an idealist
as i experienced more in life i realized
much like george that one has to be able
to balance their ideology with the
reality of the world around them
once c nation ended o'brien continued to
work in genre tv
however the role she played changed from
idealistic leaders to hardened bad gals
after a season of playing the strong and
compassionate george on z nation
o'brien used her martial arts tone
physicality to embody a different kind
of determined character
in the cw series black lightning an
aeroverse show based on the dc comics
character of the same name she plays
major sarah gray a soldier with the
nefarious american security agency or
asa she's introduced in the third season
as a strong woman for agent o'dell
played by bill duke
when he's injured major grey even takes
over command unlike the character
of george who constantly faced difficult
decisions to put her desire to do good
at odds with the circumstances at hand
major grey's motivations are much
simpler as o'brien told comicbook.com
it's less of me having to take the time
to really get into the emotions of the
character because that's i pretty much
know
i have a mission and i need to
accomplish it the relentless drive to
complete a mission made major grey a
formidable antagonist during o'brien's
run on the show
o'brien completed her trifecta of
playing villainous henchwoman on major
sci-fi tv properties when she was cast
in the marvel series agents of shield as
kimball a member of nathaniel malek's
team
the group is made up of baddies who
slipped past their predestined deaths by
jumping through time and space
and considering that malik was born into
a hydro family you better believe that
one of the main priorities
for this group of time traveling terrors
was to destroy shield
sadly for kimball she put her money on
the wrong megalomaniac horse
a fate she found out when she and the
rest of malik's crew were obliterated by
daisy johnson aka
quake while the series finale of agents
of shield may have had her thumbing
through the evil henchwoman wanted ads
o'brien clearly found a good fit for
herself now that she's becoming a more
established presence within the
mandalorian
we're sure to see katie o'brien putting
her talents to use all over tv and film
in the future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you